[Music]
man you
you have about six missions going at all
times in your life you're you gotta
you're a driven guy a crusader in a
whole bunch of different areas at one
time so this is perfect what's the
driving force to do a book called
mission possible encouragement
encouragement and people's worth their
value and their purpose in life and why
i wanted the right mission possible was
because i wanted to encourage people one
when you you know you have a mission
means you know you have purpose and two
when you know it's possible you have
encouragement for endurance and for
stamina in your race and i want to
encourage people that it's not
impossible
to have a life that counts
we get to we get to have a life that
truly counts god has made that possible
i believe he's given every single one of
us purpose he's given every single one
of us a mission a mission means a task
or a job someone is given to do and
actually the origin of the world means
to sin and i believe every single one of
us has been sent here for a mission for
a purpose for a plan and that is
possible possible means to be able that
mission we are able to accomplish that
mission to truly make our life count and
you know so many people are going to say
well you know what i i think what i need
to really run after is money fame and
power status and all these other things
and i'm here to say you could have all
those things and you could still be
empty and not really have anything right
be careful if you run after them you
might catch them you might catch them
but you know what if you run after
purpose and worth and value and meaning
you might catch them too you might catch
them and i believe when you do that
you're going to truly have a life that
counts so what i think is interesting is
like what you just contrasted right
there right of like what the world what
you feel like would fill you up you know
that's right power fame money all of
these things right it's gonna make me
feel better versus going after almost
this
not tangible side of life of
value purpose having something that you
is so much different so talk about that
contrasting because you've kind of but
that's god's economy right is we
actually think what when we give we have
less that's not true when we give we
actually have more in god's economy and
what's crazy is that science and studies
actually back that up we talk about one
study from the university i know they're
miami so it's hard to mention them but
we can now you have that nasty little
orange tea thing over there whatever
we'll let it let it go it's fine that's
what grace is for guys honestly it's
totally fine
that's exactly right i know but but we
talk about the this study and it's
fascinating because the the this um this
these groups write down one thing every
day they're grateful for and then other
groups write down things that they don't
like and then there's different groups
in here and the group that would write
down you think it's nothing right one
day write down or every day write down
one thing you're grateful for it had a a
biochemical positive change
in their life in their body from the
inside out just by writing down one
thing they're grateful for so gratitude
changes your life but also there's
another study about a helper's eye when
you choose to actually serve and give
selflessly to other people you also have
a biochemical positive reaction from the
inside out and it's crazy wait a second
to actually do these things to choose to
be grateful to choose to help
not only do i have an emotional response
but i actually have a chemical response
for the better that's crazy and you live
longer
and you have a higher quality of life in
the process no doubt oh yeah rachel's
got a gratitude journal that we put out
right do i contentment journal content
but gratitude's one of the steps to
contentment because it is it's like when
you're
able to have peace with where you're at
we're to put you i'm like there's
there's a level of power there that that
brings there's gratitude is that first
step and i feel like one of the things
that um that we're fighting right now
and we're talking about it before the
show right now is comparison and why
would you
literally another study com came out
that said 12 of our daily thoughts are
spent on some form of comparison when
you are spending your life comparing
yourself against other people what
you're really saying is god i'm not
happy i'm not grateful i'm not content
of where you put me and i need to be
like somebody else listen if god wanted
you to be like someone else he would
have made you like somebody else but he
didn't he created you with a design and
with the plan for to be exactly who you
are and to make the most out of what he
has given you you are created in love by
love and for love and he has a great
plan and purpose for your life you have
a mission and a mission is possible but
before you can answer that mission you
have to know there is a mission you have
to know that i'm here on purpose and
when you know that you're here on
purpose i don't have to spend my whole
life wishing i was somebody else because
the god of this universe who was
sovereign in control of all of it
in his design and hid in his wisdom and
in his love for us he made me who i am
for a reason and he didn't make a
mistake and he didn't make a mistake on
you okay so for someone out there that's
listening
and they're like this is great tim
absolutely gosh i want that i'm longing
for that everything you're saying but
yes like how does someone start when
someone does feel like that they're in
the cycle of comparison or the cycle so
good hopelessness yes what's the thing
to be like okay how do i connect to my
god-given design how do i connect to my
guys that's such a good question and
it's one of the things that we really
try to focus on here is we talk about
the principles kind of from a very you
know 30 000 foot view but then we also
want to get into the practical of the
every single day and a lot of people
come and say timmy how do i know what my
mission what my calling my purpose is
and i'll first say i don't know exactly
but have your eyes ever been opened to a
knee to a hurting person to um a church
that's doing something too cool to a
non-profit that you feel really strongly
towards and have your has your heart
ever felt compassion to want to step up
and do something for that hurting person
or that person in the hospital or that
person in the old folks home or a person
on the side of the street if so that's
probably god saying hey i want you to go
meet that need and when you step out
with that little bit of courage with
that little bit of faithfulness with
that little bit of of boldness and you
do that a lot of times you don't know
the the end road the end that the the
destination but when you say yes i feel
like god shows you as you continue to
grow and and you for me as when i was 15
years old and i was in the jungles of
the philippines and i met a boy who was
born with his feet on backwards and
because of that he was viewed as cursed
as insignificant as less than and he was
a throwaway but god was like he's not a
throwaway to me and he better not be a
throwaway to you and because of that you
know i knew that was my calling and
we've i you know and i know till that my
last breath that that's gonna be my
calling is fighting for every single boy
or girl around the world like him yeah
and being obedient in the small things
that's right and the small things there
is this strange dance we have
that mixes into this message um
and around here we always quote saint
ambrose uh
pray like it all depends on god work
like it all depends on you that's right
and so
sometimes i meet people of faith who uh
need to get off their tail yes and go do
something yes and sometimes i meet
people of faith who are a little bit too
dependent on their own power and they
missed out on they missed out on
exponential yes because they didn't do
both yeah you've got to do the planting
so that you're going to reap what you
sow you've got to do the work you've got
to do
no discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
you've got to do those things and then
god comes along and joins if you keep
your arms open right i was literally
listening to a sermon on sunday and he
he brought up both of those and then he
said do both do both right we need to
have faith that that god is is sovereign
and god is in control and we need to
have faith knowing that that you know we
got to do
what we're called to do but he's going
to do what he wants to do and he's in
control of all of it but we also are
called co-laborers for a reason
co-workers and also we know that he's
given us a mission a job a
responsibility
but are we truly going after it
like it depends on us
and honestly i that's one of the reasons
why my dad is my biggest hero because
his entire adult life he has truly gone
after and i got to see all these other
people in the church and they would talk
about it and they would raise their hand
it was all this cool stuff but i was
like
but you don't do anything
it's it's really cool but man i just i
wanted to be like my dad because he was
all about it
he was all about it his whole entire
adult life i saw him loving people that
could literally not do anything for him
yeah you see i didn't want to be that
person that
i would i would talk about god's love
for humanity but you know what when when
we look at scripture and we look at
god's love which is agape the four types
of love in the greek and in agape being
most admirable you know and the best
definition i've ever heard of it was to
choose the best interest for another
person and act on their behalf but you
know what's in the bible more than agape
is agapa oh
because agape is the noun agapato is the
verb
it's in the bible more
than agape why because it's one thing to
know about god's love it's a whole
nother thing to go out there and show
god's love to choose the best interest
for humanity and act on their behalf and
you know what i think there's going to
be a lot of people one day that they're
going to know that right now they know
about god's love but man they didn't
choose to go act because i think the
most selfish thing that you can do is
once you you have been rescued
as you know about what god sent his son
jesus to do and you believe that it what
he did on the cross and you believe it
counted for you and my pastor always
says once you've been rescued you're on
the rescue team yeah go beyond the
rescue team go bring that that mission
go bring that message go bring that
opportunity to every single person
around the world because the most
selfish thing you can do is once you
know that
to hold on to it to not bring and show
that love to the world and i don't want
to be someone that that that that
knowledge stops with me i want i want to
be a i want to be a verb listen i was
homeschooled but i know the difference
between a noun and a verb all right
listen i i want i want to show it might
be why you know that yeah oh you went to
tennessee we can explain it a little bit
okay
but honestly you know
i i believe every day we share the
gospel but every now and then we use
words
and when those two match now i think you
have great impact you need to keep in
mind florida's a really good school it
is and i went to tennessee and there's a
lot of people that went to florida that
worked for me
it's cool just keep it up just keep it
up let's let's
let's talk about the glory days and you
can talk about the early 90s okay
you know it's cool that is true i
remember when to celebrate i had to look
back 30 years no
hard reaction oh
they just keep coming so no it's awesome
let's go back and celebrate peyton and t
martin and i was like it's cool you know
96 and seven were awesome years old
it's a jersey that's that's 35 years old
you're like that's set yeah it's okay
it's true it's being a ball fan
we're dedicated
fcc but two we freaking need them to be
good again like come on and they're
getting back at least this year they're
exciting with their offense hello
gunslinger yeah
one of the greatest questions you can
ask is does my life change other
people's lives for the better that's one
of the statements towards the end of the
book and uh one of my best friend's
pastor that's that's graduated he's gone
on to be with the lord you should say if
it's not helpful
if it doesn't promote healing and it
doesn't spread hope why are you doing it
yeah and so you get to the end and go
you know did i leave an impact did i
leave a mark that's right and that's how
you know if your own mission that's
right
and you know i believe that uh one of
the greatest forms of tragedy is to be
successful in all the things that don't
matter
and i think there's going to be a lot of
people one day that are going to look
back and they're going to say you know
what i was successful in all of these
things but none of them matter and man i
just don't want to
say that or feel that or know that about
my life is you know i've been fortunate
in a few areas to be a little bit
successful
man but
success is
doesn't matter but i do think that every
single person that has been blessed to
have a little bit of success i believe
that we can turn that into significance
because i believe success is about us
but significance is about other people
and i would encourage all those people
that are listening right now and you've
been blessed with with success you have
the chance to turn that into
significance by looking outward by
looking at people that need you that
need that help and you can make a
difference in their life because what
are you going to think one day
oh my gosh what are you going to brag
about in your death bed look at all the
success i had i've been fortunate to
talk to a lot of people on their
deathbed whether that's been in
hospitals it's been in death row it's
been in so many different places in so
many different countries and very rarely
do you ever hear someone talk about an
accomplishment yep but you do hear them
talk about meaning
and purpose or you hear them say
i wish i would have done more
meaning purpose significance things that
actually really mattered
yep that's exactly right yeah you don't
uh
get to the end of the end of the thing
and somebody worry about what car
they're driving it doesn't it doesn't
come up no but he with the most stories
when he dies is dead that's right but
but i will say this i'll tell you
honestly so many times in my life i i
will say that i have gotten caught up in
that i think man i i've so many times
i've gotten caught up i thought man but
if we can win this championship man but
if we can beat tennessee again man but
but but if we can win the sec man but if
we can win this championship man but but
if we can if i can prove the doubter is
wrong and be a first round draft pick if
we can prove them wrong and get to the
playoffs you know and those aren't bad
things but too many times in my life
they were everything yeah and and god
had to say no no no that's not
everything that's a game
and it's okay i know you love it that's
a good thing i've put you here for that
but but remember i didn't put you here
for a game
you know i remember i was uh i just won
the the heisman trophy and then a few
weeks later i was in thailand i got a
chance to do some cool things and i saw
a boy that was starving on the side of
of this feeding center that was
squatting in this corner of a ditch and
he was wearing an orange and blue number
15 tim tebow jersey and i just started
weeping because i knew god was pricking
my heart saying you think that you're
cool or you think that you matter
because you just won this trophy and
people are celebrating you
who's celebrating that boy you see i
died just as much for that boy as i died
for you
and you know what a game's not going to
do anything for that boy but you can
so don't remember why you don't forget
why you're here don't forget why i died
i didn't die for a game i died for
humanity i died for that boy
i want you to love that boy
yeah and that's so much too of like
even here on this show when we just talk
about money right like that's like the
big
arc of it and it's like you know getting
people in this place to be free and to
have the margin the ability to go and
give right now that we're mad at stuff
right whether it's winning a football
game or driving a nice whatever like all
that's not bad it's not bad but but it's
the thing that you're attaching your
hope and your joy to that's exactly
right so i think that's i think that's
awesome the new book is mission possible
go create a life that counts with our
friend tim tebow thanks for coming by my
brother thank you guys i always
appreciate it
thank you i'm so grateful for y'all you
too brother